volver a ondear la bandera de Francia
empañada en gran medida en África es el
desafío lanzado por Emanuel
mapa sobre la mesa con Francia que
intenta reinventar su relación con el
continente africano primer punto
repensar y reducir la presencia militar
en estas cinco bases permanentes excepto
en yibutti
más de 6000 soldados franceses están
desplegados actualmente en África
Cuántos permanecerán luego de las
reformas no se sabe por el momento
estas bases serán transformadas en
academias militares y colegios y lo más
importante es que serán coadministradas
por las fuerzas armadas de cada país lo
que resulta lógico para muchos africanos
en pleno centro de París de ámsterdam o
de Londres Así que es anacrónico tener
una base militar francesa en un país
soberano en una capital soberana
la desconfianza con respecto a Francia
gana terreno en África como en Mali Y en
burkina faso donde las tropas francesas
tuvieron que retirarse la operación
antiterrorista bacán en el sahell acabó
debido a constantes errores
nosotros queríamos ser los gendarmes del
sahel y mientras tanto nuestros socios
europeos que no nos ayudaron en el campo
militar hacían negocios
Francia que era el primer importador
europeo en África en 2017 fue Doblado
por Alemania grandes pérdidas para el
comercio francés el vínculo comercial
entre Francia y África pasó de más del
10% en 2002 A menos del 4% en la
actualidad mientras aumenta
vertiginosamente el vínculo de África
con china Turquía India y Rusia
nosotros todavía tenemos muchas empresas
que no generan trabajos de mejor calidad
porque se trata de África no funcionará
más así
para África un continente globalizado
ahora Francia sólo es un país más entre
todos
[Música]